c'est un véritable ultimatum que les
chefs de l'état de la cédéao non c'est
aux nouvelles autorités maliennes de
bamako il donne une semaine à la junte
militaire pour désigner un président de
transition ainsi que son premier
ministre
toutes les sanctions prises à l'encontre
de la junte sont maintenus en attendant
ibrahim boubacar keita a été autorisé à
quitter le territoire pour rejoindre les
émirats arabes unis pour se faire
soigner
le mali a été un sujet longuement abordé
par emmanuel macron l ivoirien alassane
ouattara lors de leur rencontre à paris
il ya quelques jours une rencontre
discrète et pour cause
alassane ouattara entend briguer un
troisième mandat présidentiel en côte
d'ivoire suite au soudan décès à
d'amadou gon coulibaly
pourtant en mars il avait annoncé ne pas
se représenter une déclaration alors
saluée par emmanuel macron je salue la
décision historique du président
ouattara homme de parole et homme d'état
a de ne pas se présenter à la prochaine
élection présidentielle
ce soir la côte d'ivoire donne l'exemple
finalement ouattara est de retour dans
la course depuis cette annonce le pays
est secoué par des manifestations à
travers le pays ayant fait au moins une
quinzaine de morts
malgré la candidature de ouattara est un
pays sens dessus dessous
silence radio du côté de la france un
difficile jeu d'équilibriste pour
emmanuel macron qui tantôt encourage
ouattara à ne pas se représenter pour
finalement l'accueillir à bras ouverts
alors qu'il est candidat
un revirement qui semble aujourd'hui
métro paris dans l'embarras qui se
passerait volontiers d'une nouvelle
crise électorale en côte d'ivoire
au vu de tous les intérêts français sur
le plan économique la côte d'ivoire est
le premier partenaire commercial de
paris au sein de la zone franc cfa et le
deuxième en afrique subsaharienne à du
côté militaire les forces françaises
bénéficient d'un statut de force de
présence et constitue l'une des deux
bases opérationnelles avancées en
afrique
emmanuel macron est fidèle à sa doctrine
du en même temps veut être présent mais
sans trop l'être
reste que cette visite a comme un air de
campagne présidentielle ivoirienne dans
l'hexagone alors que le chef de l'état
avait répété à plusieurs reprises qu'il
fallait se débarrasser est des vestiges
de la françafrique
je suis d'une génération de français
pour qui les crimes de la colonisation
européenne
elles sont incontestables et font partie
de notre histoire
je suis d'une génération où l'on ne
vient pas dire à l'afrique ce qu'elle
doit faire
quelles sont les règles de l'état de
droit mais où partout on encouragera
celles et ceux qui en afrique veulent
prendre leurs responsabilités en
attendant cette rencontre sonne comme
une acceptation pour l'opposition
ivoirienne votre parole est très attendu
en ne cautionnant pas ce coup de force
institutionnel en exigeant des élections
transparentes et inclusives vous serez
fidèle aux valeurs démocratiques issues
des lumières dont la france est porteuse
puisque en vous exprimant une première
fois vous êtes désormais partie prenante
dans le débat politique ivoirien
votre silence face à la forfaiture qui
se dessine serait incompréhensible pire
aux yeux de beaucoup il vaudrait
complicité à nicolas sarkozy françois
hollande emmanuel macron tous avaient
déclaré vouloir changer la politique
africaine de la france
mais la françafrique semble avoir la vie
dure et l'ascendant de la france sur le
continent africain pourrait toujours
être en marche